now a sunny bank holiday weekend would
usually be amongst the busiest days of
the year on the roads and in tourist
beauty spots but as government officials
from all of the UK's nation's urged
people to stay at home it's the police
so expected to put those restrictions in
practice well joining us now is the
Chief Constable of Northamptonshire
police Nick Adly mr. Edley thank you
very much indeed for being with us and
and you're pretty much as far as people
in your patch are concerned you're
assuring them with a warning today well
we've wished that things up here because
we've given the public three weeks to
get used to this this is a massive
change in terms of their lifestyle and
how they can operate we've worked on the
basis of engagements and information and
from today I'm being really clear that
if people continue to flout the law that
they will be fined and if appropriate
they will be arrested but I do want to
make the point of the vast vast majority
here in Northamptonshire and I hear from
colleagues across the country are
abiding by the law and to those people I
say thank you it is just a minority that
we now need to hone in on do you
actually have the powers to arrest
people if they disobey you well known in
the coronavirus bill the corona virus
bill is fairly clear in terms of the
fines but what we do have of course is
the wide-ranging powers that police
officers having carry in any case so
where people break the law in terms of
antisocial behavior or in public order
and the link to coronavirus then
actually they will get arrested for that
offense and they will be charged with
that offense on the corona virus or a
coded bill offence - so you can define
things like you know refusing to stop
sunbathing or gathering in big groups
you can actually define that as
antisocial behavior and if they refuse
to stop doing it you can or you believe
your officers can arrest them
yes it's an option and what I'm saying
is that we've got to get really serious
with this people are dying every day
we're experiencing this here in the
county and wider across the country
we're seeing doctors we've seen
consultants and nurses dying as they're
sacrificing their lives to protect us it
is only right that we ask the public to
play their part and in the main they are
but it's that hard core of individuals
that if they refuse yes it could be
issued with that ticket if they continue
to refuse to move on or to go home as
being requested there are other powers
which could mean that those individuals
will be arrested and actually those
people will then end up with a criminal
record which is just not worth it the
more important point is by going home
and following the law you are saving
lives and protecting our valuable NHS
yeah it's gonna ask you about your
officers because of course they are
coming into contact now with people face
to face more there's an upsurge in
domestic violence so presumably they are
more more exposed as well than usual
yeah absolutely and here in
Northamptonshire we are around 135
officers who are currently off sick and
self isolating and of course as they do
every day they put themselves in harm's
way and this is no different other than
its more acute and that risk is very
real very present and as I say we have a
number of people who are suffering as a
consequence of that the personal
protective equipment we have here is
plentiful we still have to do that we
still have to put ourselves in harm's
way
but we will do that we don't want to do
that we do want full compliance but if
necessary the men and women of this
force and every force across the country
will do exactly that and yes they put
themselves at risk but that's what we're
doing here to say the wider community is
from from further spread of this awful
disease and undeath Chief Constable Nick
a delay of a North Hampshire thank you
very much indeed for joining us